it's Tuesday March 22nd I'm Mary and
you're watching GameSpot news this is
actually kind of a sad news day today
and we're starting it off with a
send-off to driveclub developer
evolution studios which will be sadly
closing down driveclub developer
evolution Studios has been closed by its
parent company Sony according to a
statement issued to GameSpot the closure
was enacted as part of a restructure to
its European studios Sony said it will
attempt to shift some developers from
evolution studios which are known from
their work on World Rally Championship
and MotorStorm franchises to other teams
Evolution community manager Jamie
Bradshaw also released a statement on
evolutions closure it's the end of an
incredible era for evolution studios
driveclub will live on under the care of
the awesome team at PlayStation and we
hope it will continue to thrive in their
safe hands with a continued support from
all of you the players our community
thank you for everything evolution
studios we're gonna miss you and in
other sad news Japanese outlet Nikkei
has reported that the Wii U will stop
production this year Japanese newspaper
Nikkei reported today that Nintendo will
cease production of the Wii U by the end
of 2016
presumably switching to manufacturing
for the mysterious and X system Nikkei
which has accurately reported news about
Nintendo's unannounced plans before says
Nintendo is ending production on the Wii
U Hardware so soon due to the consoles
slow sales which are not expected to
improve the report translated by
GameSpot and dual shockers does not
contain any details on when the NX will
launch or when Nintendo plans to stop
selling Wii U hardware to consumers it's
no secret that the Wii U has come up
short system which went on sale November
2012 has sold 12 point 6 million units
around the world
compare that 201 million for the Wii
well it's just never gonna make it
but the Wii of course was a massive
global hit a matching that success was
always going to be a challenge for tiny
brother we use
finally we question quantum break and
the technical tricks they use to get to
1080p but remedy entertainment insists
it's complicated it's totally not at
720p quantum break developer Remedy
Entertainment has released a statement
addressing the game's resolution and the
discussion around it the game was
expected to run at 1080p but evidence
has indicated it doesn't properly reach
this speaking to Inquisitor the studio
explains that its dev implemented a
number of technical tricks to achieve
1080p which makes talking about
resolution as it is traditionally
understood complicated according to the
statement the game uses 720p as its
foundation and then it applies temporal
reconstruction this means the previous
frames are incorporated into the
following ones to create a sharper image
the developer went on to say the studio
has always placed a greater focus on
delivering a compelling gaming
experience with superior artistic
quality over hitting technical
milestones and believes it's achieved
its goal digital foundry which
extensively tested the game said that
quantum break even at its reported 720p
resolution still remains visually
impressive stunning in many areas well
that was a pretty sad news day well I'll
pour one out for your homies and I will
see you guys again tomorrow